as an offense as a team we've been in
that situation there multiple times and
know we've answered the bell and just
it's tough when you know that one time
meal yeah so but that's what that's what
people remember it's a world we live in
and you just got owned up to it you know
be a man about it so it'll uh like I
said be plural you listen this offseason
fueled me especially in this offseason
just to uh no come back better Jimmy
Garoppolo 49ers quarterback at his
locker yesterday Locker clean-out day
the ritual for every team when the
season is finally over you meet with the
media you say a few things and you know
he knows what happened he knows what
went wrong and they did answer the bell
from time to time throughout the season
but you know that was the question I had
all year long that's right what's he
gonna do in a big spot yeah we finally
saw the biggest possible spot for his
third and ten from the forty nine with
exactly 100 seconds left in the NFL's
100 season Emmanuel Sanders was open and
he missed him yeah and other guys would
have made that throw and and to me it's
the ultimate litmus test championship
throw just like Jared golf last year
when he had Brandon cooks wide open saw
him late through it wobbly Jason
McCourty came over and made the play to
keep cooks from catching it that's that
that's the test and we've seen over the
years guys make the throw Terry Bradshaw
making the turn Superbowl ten the cover
of Sports Illustrated that I tweeted
earlier today from Super Bowl 14 the
throw to John Stallworth when the
Steelers were down in Super Bowl 14 to
the Rams right over the outstretched
fingertips of the defensive back that's
what you do in those moments or you
don't it has failed some have passed
some have failed and Garoppolo until he
gets another chance to pass on his
permanent record the most recent grade
is F Chris yeah well I you know listen I
I don't want to say F but I understand
what you're saying pass fail if you
don't pass what do you do well okay I
get it you know I
okay so first off I I really respect
Jimmy G one for the way he's handled
this whole situation I mean the postgame
press conference what we saw yesterday
at his locker all of those things
I mean he's not he's not shying away
from it he you know he tells you just
like we saw in that clip he gets it he
understands the criticism you got to be
a man about it go forward I love all
those answers I really do
here's a guy again I think it's very
easy to root for it now where I think we
get a little swayed with this whole
conversation first off but balls being
thrown in the air for 40-plus yards the
completion percentage is not very high
it's not around the league it's around
40% the lower 40% I mean Patrick mahomes
I believe for the year on 40-plus yard
throws in the air was six for 15 now
that's the other problem with this as we
saw mahomes deliver on all these throws
at the end of the football game and then
we're trying to hold Jimmy Garoppolo to
that standard - hey Jimmy Garoppolo is
not Patrick mahomes he never gonna be
patrick mahomes like I said yesterday is
in another stratosphere he's in outer
space and Garoppolo is down here in the
United States right I mean that's where
he is is that's just a simple fact of
the matter
mahomes Terry Bradshaw yeah those are
like super super talented guys ma I mean
Bradshaw was the number one pick of the
draft
mahomes as we know was the number one
player on some boards Sean Payton we
know fancied him another bunch of other
people did too he's a special special
talent so it's not even fair to my homes
or Garoppolo to compare those two that's
Tom Brady was pick number 199 I get it I
mean I got there's plenty of guys who
can make that throw I just picked out
Terry Bradshaw because I remember those
throws from my childhood there were
plenty of quarterbacks who have made
big-time throws in big-time spots with
championships on the line and grew up a
lot had a chance to become one of nine
you didn't I know I know but you but
yeah you know you say that and I get it
and I go yeah but like okay like you
name - and history of the Super Bowl
like there's not that many that were
that the team is down by four and the
guy throws the bomb to win the game
there's not there's not that many and
then I don't like the Oh Garoppolo and
Shanahan they're not good in the big
game you know like I just I don't like
it's a shame a lie no but because people
have said that to me too I go and do
radio interviews and they talk about
that and like I just want to go well I
mean damn I thought the NFC Championship
was this big game last time I checked I
mean you know that was big week 17 in
Seattle was big the game in New Orleans
was big I know it's not the Super Bowl
but they were still big moments where he
came through and I just I'm just trying
to add a little bit of I guess what to
me my reality of what I see here and I
think there was some good yes it didn't
end the way we wanted it to end but I
think it was more because of the magic
of the guide number 15 wearing red and
yellow than anything more about me
looking at his negatives and Garoppolo
didn't play his best game I get that he
missed some passes and made a few bad
decisions down the stretch he did have
some good moments though and we have the
top-5 Jimmy G highlights from 2019 his
first full season as a starter he had
been started for part of 2016 part of
2017 part of 2018 2019 wire-to-wire
let's take a look at the top highlights
and we will talk through them as best we
can for a radio audience number 5
happened in week 12 on a Sunday night
Green Bay was in town it was 23 to 8 at
that point the Packers had scored a
touchdown and the okey-doke with kiddo
going right instead of left and Jimmy G
finds him wide open Kittel scores the
touchdown supplies the dagger next one
game-winning touchdown pass against
Arizona a close exciting game and yellow
was a little weak 17 how about this ah
I had to wait for a little bit could
have scored if he'd hit him in-stride
I'm just trying to be a jury larger
don't worry this one's on target it was
a 5 yard pass to debo and yellow hey
Jimmy Garoppolo had his moments here's
132 16 remember this Saturday night game
against the red to third and 16s on the
same Drive rye he gets him and he gets
Kendrick born the first time and then
he's got Emmanuel Sanders this was a
thing of beauty
there was you know he is he is capable
right of doing it here and look here hey
things break down he's got to move to
his left against the Saints in that
epoch finds a guy in the back of the end
zone is a fourth down throw to Oh and
then here's the four South Rota to
George kid oh boy this was the the game
decider so much moment can do it he
can't do it right he can do it but he
didn't do it in the surface no he didn't
do in the Super Bowl and I'm not trying
to get an excuse but that's what I want
to hear though he can do it I think
that's ultimately what Kyle Shanahan
will go back to and go I I think this
guy can do it he came through it a lot
of times for that football team this
year yeah it wasn't his best performance
in the Super Bowl
it wasn't yeah he missed a few throws
and hey I think that's an area of the
game you know - you open the segment and
you mentioned it you know we questioned
all year in a big moment or when the run
game of the 49ers is not hitting on all
cylinders can Garoppolo pull them
through you know more times than not he
did during the year the Super Bowl he he
let them down to a degree I know that
but that's what's amazing to me about
football at football especially the NFL
at some point and usually the playoffs
your greatest weakness is going to come
to the forefront and it's gonna be okay
this is your greatest weakness and the
games being boiled down to it right now
let's see how much you've improved on
that weakness as the year went on and
can that get you over the hump like
every team is I always kind of seems to
find their play their kryptonite and
whether they can handle it and you know
Kansas City one of their strengths was
their nickel and third down defense all
year long one of the weaknesses of the
49ers was yes the drop back pass game
and maybe some of the inconsistencies
throughout the year with the Jimmy
Garoppolo questions and it came to a
head and the biggest moment and of
course the Kansas City Chiefs and their
defense and nickel defense prevailed he
talked yesterday about using what
happened in the Super Bowl is fuel to
get better where would you tell him he
needs to improve going into 2020 I've
said this a lot during the year and his
deep ball throwing is that it's average
and they don't throw the ball deep a lot
into in general to begin with that's
another thing there I mean I think he
threw one of the the least amount of
like 40 plus yards passes and football
this year he was towards the bottom of
the list on those attempts and yes his
his mechanics are not great that way
Mike think about the game the other
night every throw we saw was right in
between the numbers right over the
middle of the field right you heard me
say that all he throws I can think of
that were not right down the middle
somewhere in the you know 5 to 12 yard
range were the Kittel offensive pass
interference play and the deep post to
Emmanuel Sanders everything else was you
know kid all over the middle D Bo
Samuel over the middle Emmanuel Sanders
there was one other there was one other
what was it a third and five flight when
he was freaked out about throwing over
the middle again because Chris Jones
batted down the same the guy was open
over the middle again that was you know
we showed that yesterday right Kindle
was open you're right so that's there's
three throws that just tells you one I
don't think he's great at it too I think
Shannon had probably realizes it and
three that's somewhere here I do think
he can improve his career here how about
this yeah let's set aside hash tag Tommy
picking up the phone and calling Kyle
and saying I'd like to play for you in
2020 yeah Kirk Cousins contract goes
through the 2020 season yeah
and they can't use the transition tag on
him next year that's part of the
contract they won't use the franchise
tag because since he was tagged twice in
Washington he'd be entitled to a 44%
raise over his cap number for this
year's cap numbers 31 million a 44% ray
he's already done the math forty four
point six four million is what his
one-year franchise tender would be in
2021 the Vikings aren't going to do that
so unless they extend Kirk Cousins
before next March I know Kirk Kyle right
get together so maybe yeah maybe you
give him one more year right and this is
it and it's gonna loom over the whole
season because if Jimmy doesn't get it
done this year bye bye Jimmy next year
hello Kirk I I'll entertain this
conversation I like this a little bit
more this is a little more realistic
than Tommy calling up Kyle and like that
whole thing I like this one I think
there's there's some realness to it
you're right like what if Minnesota
misses out on the playoffs or maybe gets
in the wild-card game and loses and the
49ers don't get in next year what if
they're nine and seven or eight and
eight and they kind of have a fall off
year Super Bowl loss as well no before
then but you're right to say they're
going to extend him or they're not it
doesn't matter what happens with a
Vikings season yeah he can walk away he
can go wherever he well he's Tom Brady
next you can go anywhere he wants no I'm
just saying that would be like yes let's
just say the Vikings get there and have
a good year or whatever maybe they go to
the playoffs maybe they just miss out
the 49ers miss out I'm with you is what
I'm saying is I think Shanahan would
think about that like okay maybe Jimmy
G's not the guy I still love Kirk
Cousins and think he can come in here
and orchestrate and run
offense better than a Jimmy G and I
would think Kirk Cousins I think he
realizes the greatness of Shanahan at
this point I think he's realized like
damn playing quarterback for him was
easier than anybody else I played with
me people were wide open all the time we
just talked about Jimmy Garoppolo threw
the ball over the middle to wide open
guys all year long that I could see
happening Mike he talked about it last
week with us he did his rookie year
right right first who cares it was
off-camera yeah first game of his rookie
year right Robert Griffin the third
rookie quarterback Kirk Cousins fourth
round rookie backup and they destroyed
the Saints night and he said he'ii come
call his dad right now I called his holy
crap yeah yeah he said to somebody holy
crap this Cal Shannon knows what he's
doing right he couldn't get over he just
thought like oh my gosh the the game
went on and they just you know they they
were a well-oiled machine and people
were open everywhere and yet that's
where you know I constantly hear this
from players who play for Kyle receivers
and quarterbacks they just go man I've
never seen anything like it he always
gets me open he knows how to get me the
ball I mean it's the one thing over and
over you hear about Shanahan from
players that play with him because he
gives you rhyme and reason to why he's
running schemes and plays and you start
to understand whoa that's smart that's
next-level thinking and you know makes
you buy-in makes you want to play
because you know you're gonna get the
ball get stats and it's gonna be
exciting football I always root for a
great story and wouldn't it be a great
story if Tom Brady was the quarterback
in San Francisco they trade for Odell
Beckham jr. who they almost dropped my
last year and then when he emerges from
his suspension Antonio Brown joins your
name in Santa Clara with a Super Bowl
great days after the Super Bowl you're
already going down to mid-may Florio
theory
we got a stir man we got to talk about
this stuff that's our job our job is to
get people thinking and talking about
the possibilities and the possibilities
this year are endless and I am NOT
rolling out the possibility that Tom
Brady is gonna pick up that phone and
he's gonna say hello Kyle this is Tom
let's do some business together and if
it works I'll get your initials tattooed
on
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports